hello everyone
hello everyone and welcome I'm good at
words it's been a long day uh we'll just
do it we're doing another chat this is
the fourth one of these I think we've
done look at us guys yeah uh next to me
is Young you might know from youtube.com
and then Ralph down there youtube.com
skillup and then Jake baldino down there
who you might know from gamerx or
youtube.com Jake baldino you guys are
all so efficient what the [ __ ] is
Charles
that's cool it's a cool name thanks man
the story of that uh I just put my name
in the middle of Charizard when I was oh
I see yeah
and ran with it it was my gamertag so it
just persisted I guess Charizard
no Gyarados is my favorite Pokemon
that's the weirdest part interesting
yeah fascinating okay okay in any case
doesn't sound as good garalana Dos well
I mean Rebrand it kind of works
um we're going to talk about you know
the last few months of video games
mostly how this year's not E3 went but I
wanted to start out our chat today to
talk about steam deck because you all
got them I do not have one how is
everybody feeling about the steam deck
the future is bright the future is real
good I feel like I we ended the last one
with me just kind of like ranting about
it like you guys I swear it's amazing so
yeah it still it still is and yang you
just got yours the prophecies you
relayed were true all of them the
Legends I mean it's an amazing amazing
device and what what really stands out
about this one compared to the ones that
I've used is how well games perform on
this thing yeah
um it just I don't know what it is about
whatever a proprietary thing they did
with the AMD chip on the steam deck but
it just runs like control I can play at
low settings like 45 to 60 frames per
second and on low that game still looks
great on the other device it was like
you know 30 to 45 even I don't know what
this thing does that the others don't
but the AAA games are actually small the
graphics don't have to travel this fall
the frames get to the screen faster yes
it downloads the frames faster because
of gigabit exactly no but uh
no but seriously it's it's an amazing
thing and and I love the different
inputs I I use this trackpad a lot for
like shooter games and I know it takes a
little getting used to but like being
able to swipe this thing and like turn
180 and then like hold down on the
trackpad and then use the Gyros to fine
tune your aiming and stuff like that
that's like a game changer for shooters
for me that does not sound appealing at
all so it's cool that it is yeah it is
if you get used to it yeah it does take
some getting used to and if not if you
like the analogues passive touch right
here if you keep your finger on it you
can still use the Gyros and I I think
the Gyros are way undervalued by people
uh who haven't given it a try I
recommend it
um but I've also emulated games on this
thing and they run fantastic uh and how
could you steal from Nintendo like that
have you no conscience unbelievable oh
my God
so those are your first impressions
um Jake like you said at the last uh
time we did this ended with you kind of
ranting about uh your first impressions
how much has it changed now that you've
had more time with it uh I use it a
little less but I still appreciate I've
actually been using it more for work uh
it's it's been a good like reviewer
thing when I'm trying to like kill a
game as quick as possible I just jump to
it on the steam deck and it makes me
feel like really powerful like I can
work everywhere now my work-life balance
is even more toxic yes this is like
definitely good yeah I still think the
battery life isn't as bad as people are
cracking it up to be maybe it's because
I have my settings very specific but one
thing I've really really been digging is
just how much they they have been
updating it and they've been adding a
lot of cool stuff like fan curve
adjustments more refresh rate options
and then to see valve actually like back
it up and put out cool little social
updates and say hey look we're updating
it it's very different for valve it's
very nice as someone who used a lot of
their things that just kind of like
fizzled out this is this is good nice to
know we exist the customization of like
the refresh rate and like the TP being
able to like lower the power and the
clock speed of the GPU and stuff like
that so I I booted up Metroid Fusion
here for Game Boy Advance and that game
that does not require much uh Power at
all so I could literally uh set all of
my power settings to minimum and this
thing lasted me like seven hours wow so
you can like really fine-tune this
device to the specifications of the game
you're playing and extend the battery
life Define what your frame rate is do
you want to if it's going from like 45
to 60 you don't like the fluctuation do
you just want to keep it at 45 and just
like have the refresh right right there
it's just the amount of customizability
on this thing it can be overwhelming for
people who aren't just used to like the
thing working like you boot up the
switch and it just works you have to
tweak anything but if you're a tweaker
like me who likes you know getting
Android phones instead of iOS because I
love tweaking my phone and like
customizing it to my specifications
stuff like that this is like this is
gonna be your favorite thing
um ever Ralph I think I saw you tweet
somebody at ideal settings for a certain
game it might have been straight yeah I
don't remember it was so that's the
thing that you are considering when you
approach playing a new game is like
customizing it for each game
individually absolutely yeah I mean for
sure like I mean which I think is
similar to PCS right I mean everyone has
different PCS and so therefore you know
what are recommended specs and whatever
uh but the steam deck it's different
because the steam deck is ultimately a
console right well okay that's the thing
it straddles that line between PC and
console
um but most consoles we don't have to
think about settings we just like plug
in the thing and put in the disk or load
up the file and off it goes and maybe
there's a performance mode if we're
lucky but that's about as good as it
gets
um but with this one you actually get to
tweak it as much as you like and I feel
like that is the real breakthrough with
this device like I think I might as I'm
not sure if I said this the last time we
spoke but the most exciting thing about
steam deck is it shows an entirely
different model of what a video game
console can be from an ecosystem
perspective right where it is no longer
this Walled Garden that is completely
controlled by you know the the company
that that made it It ultimately is just
a piece of Hardware that we can do
whatever we like with you know yeah and
valve are totally down for that like
they are so okay with us just doing
whatever the [ __ ] we please so you know
whether it's settings or emulation or
side loading or whatever you want to
call it it's just a available and I love
that and you know even the way they
speak to us on Twitter like um I forget
his name Lawrence I think his name is
just the the main guy who's you know the
valve steam deck guys throwing out
updates yeah something like that yeah
throwing out updates and like hey this
we're adding this thing and talking to
people and answering questions like
when's the last time Nintendo actually
had like a conversation with someone on
any social media platform ever that just
doesn't happen even like Sony's not
really up for that Xbox is a little bit
better I find but yeah man that
different vision for how console the
console ecosystem could be is so much
more interesting to me and as I said
before I will buy whatever Nintendo
Hardware like whatever Hardware Nintendo
makes
and up to play their exclusives right
but I have no interest in any more
Nintendo handhelds now because the steam
deck is my handheld and as long as they
keep putting out new versions of that to
keep up with specs this is what I will
continue to use forever I see no reason
to um go back to steam to the switch as
my kind of handheld of choice yeah I uh
I straight up just like the the switch
was kind of becoming like my Indie
handheld yeah yeah and then when I got
the steam deck it was like I was Andy
throwing Woody in the [ __ ] toy box I
was like ceiling sorry sorry
even on the hardware front uh steam
partnered with iFixit so you could just
like buy all these individual components
and they also released the cad files of
the steam deck so you could like know
the the specifications of the exterior
so you can like really just customize it
however you want Hardware 3D print your
own stuff and like add it to the steam
deck they're really just opening it
opening it up on a level that no other
like console manufacturer does and that
I think is Nintendo scene a hit with
party sales as a result of this
I don't think so well the staff deck is
also there are still shortage of Supply
so yeah it's not like it's gonna sell
anyone here as well as the switch it's
also I think it's so well like the steam
deck is a big product in our world but
if you ask your average punter hey have
you ever heard of a steam death they're
like what the [ __ ] is that you know what
I mean yeah but uh obviously the
Nintendo switch everyone knows what that
is right yeah but I do believe that this
is such a good product that has to win
eventually and I don't mean beat
Nintendo I just mean like it will find
its place in the market it will grow it
will become this thing that people use I
don't think this is going to be like the
steam PCS and whatever where you know it
just kind of Fizzles out I reckon it is
such a good compel such a compelling
value proposition and such a fantastic
product that it will survive and um that
makes me super happy because you know I
really love it I can't wait for steam
deck too I mean that thing's gonna be
amazing but also one point as well is
that I think a lot of the narrative at
the beginning of the steam deck was like
oh it's got a lot of problems so really
you should wait for version two and it's
like I don't agree with that at all I
feel like if you bought the steam deck
today you're going to have a fantastic
time with it is there like some things
you could think could be better like the
OLED screen sure absolutely but is that
any reason to wait like oh this is just
the Prototype version no like it's a
really really good device today what are
some of the issues I don't feel like
I've seen those publicized very much uh
I just people talk about obviously the
OLED the screen is not OLED and they're
like oh that's such a disappointment and
to be fair like absolutely you know if
you really want that bright popping
screen then the switch is still going to
be better for that
um people talk about like General
reliability issues where you know
they've had things break or whatever
sure absolutely that's going to happen
with all consoles it's definitely
happened with the steam deck as well
um people talk about battery life but
again I do think to Jake's point that I
think that's a bit of an exaggeration
and if you're smart with how you set it
all up and you're just realistic I think
you get great battery life out of it
um so I'm not saying it's a perfect
device by any means but I'm just sort of
pushing back on that narrative at the
start where one's like oh this has still
got a ways to go and steam deck 2 is
going to be the one to get everyone I
know who has one seems to love it like I
said I've not seen any negativity at all
people are raving about it all the time
it's interesting you bring up the Walled
Garden thing because I feel like this is
like the prime this should be The Golden
Child for the the Walled Garden being
down and it being great I mean it's
probably a testament to just how much
Gamers have their [ __ ] together and how
much Linux nerds have their [ __ ]
together because even if you mess with
the experiences as much as possible it
still feels like a good device and still
works like yeah you can break some
things but it's not like remember like
the early days of Android where it did
just feel like the wild west and then
when Steve Jobs was like no Walled
Garden better you're like oh yeah yeah
you're right now it's like the steam
deck is like a perfect no to that yeah
totally agree and that's why I think it
has to win like there's no way that
concept does not win you know and again
I don't mean we're in a comparison no
it's the same as V what I'm saying is
like people kept thinking like it's
similar to VR there was a really long
time of people saying it's nisha's not
going to take off but I do feel like the
Oculus has found meta Quest sorry has
found a significant audience that's very
dedicated like the win is is there it
seems similar it's not like it's going
to beat Nintendo I don't know if that is
correct that it will stay is kind of the
idea definitely I was always
um
very
because I've not even like seen one I
was always concerned about it being too
big that it would be waiting and
uncomfortable so how is it for longer
play sessions
it's uh it's the most comfortable of the
devices I've used because this grip
right here is so like prominent and like
you're you're not just your fingers
don't just wrap around you're holding it
like you have a grip on it whereas the
other devices I've used there's like a
hump but it's more like your fingers are
posting over them I use my pinkies to
like hold it up way more comfortable oh
sure sure you do one of these yeah with
this you don't need to do that because
you have such a good grip on it um with
the you know potential accidental
presses of these buttons right here
maybe occasionally but other than that
it's just uh there's heft to it but it's
the device so well balanced Weight Wise
and that grip is so good that you barely
feel the weight so to me it's extremely
comfortable yeah it's big it's
definitely big but like not not to
repeat myself from my before you buy
video but it's almost like the opposite
of like a like a incredible new cell
phone where it's high-end material and
glass and you're afraid of it or even
like the OLED switch where it's very
like utilitarian plastic unassuming so
it's lighter and it's also like you're
less afraid of of it it's it's almost
easier to throw in a bag or toss on the
couch like I still don't like I still
gently toss it but it's still just way
more handleable handle ability
maneuverability feel fragile yeah
exactly and that gives it so much more
power like
it doesn't Bend like at all like I'm
trying hard right now and it just it
doesn't give it's super steady this is
great news well happy to hear that the
reviews are largely very positive uh
even after a long long play session who
would you recommend it to what kind of
people should should get
because I don't still don't feel the
need to
um and that's because I don't do a lot
of handheld gaming I love my PC setup so
much that I don't feel the need to get
one because I would always prefer to be
here on this super ultroid monitor then
holding something I see nerds and Gamers
who love to tweak stuff this is like
you're definitely your thing yeah I I
mean yes but at the same time like if
you're like okay obviously I played most
of my games on PC
the re the best use I get out of it is
by just because I work out here in this
space right but when I I think there's
something about just being close to
others even if you're doing something
else just being in the same proximity
with them right yes and what I really
like about it is that I can just go
inside the house and continue playing
exactly what I was playing on my PC the
same Cloud saved whatever and just play
it near my family you know what I mean
I'm gonna get a little hermit dog and
you're like but I want to play indoors
go back outside
um but no it is that though like it's
it's yeah it is just that thing where I
can be close to my family while I'm
doing my work you know and obviously you
know it's not like I'm ignoring them
like I get to you know whatever but it's
just that's nice you know what I mean I
think that's the biggest use that I get
out of it personally I guess I currently
do that with um with backbone and I
stream to my phone which is a dog [ __ ]
way to play video games uh in comparison
to a steam deck but that is my current
alternative it's like I just used a
little background controller and I
stream from PlayStation or Xbox or
whatever so I've also spoken to uh folks
who I I've heard like from like all
kinds of people like in my comments and
stuff like uh truck drivers people who
are driving across countries yeah um
people who commute a lot obviously but
also a lot of people in in the military
or armed service people who are like you
know on a base somewhere and that's like
they have power they have internet but
they only have so much so a lot of
people in in the service places a
service sector are like sitting around
waiting for their pre-orders from what
I've spoken to that makes sense because
then you don't lose the quality as well
I guess that that is the luxury of it
being effectively a PC that you can take
with you and that that is awesome that
accessibility is awesome how much are
they
uh from 400 to 650 there's one's on
three tiers yeah yeah it depends on it's
64 gigs 256 and 512 and it's 400 520 or
530 and then six I don't know someone
buy the cheap one by the way because it
has an SD slot and I have like a two I
have a two terabyte SD card in there so
I have like all of the games installed
and there's like it's not that much
slower to
um to install stuff super easy to mod
too yeah
you just don't need to spend that extra
money the only difference I believe is
that the high-end model has like a
different finish on the screen if I
remember exactly like a normal
anti-glare but like I don't know that
doesn't bother me I've never looked at
my steam bag I thought oh there's so
much glare on this thing uh what's your
version
the the base version they're like oh the
bass version okay um yeah I got the the
650 version and there's a noticeable
difference but it's not make or break
right like I want to use the uh like the
the 1X player I put them side by side
you can tell like the glare on the steam
deck it's a little blurrier less
prominent a little dimmer so it does
help but it's not the thing you should
buy the you know all it's only if you
really care about the 512 gigabyte
storage and you can more than make up
for that if you have the money to buy
like a two terabyte micro SD card can
steam deck support you terabyte I
thought it was up to one but maybe I
read that wrong maybe I've missed
remembering I just got the biggest one
it might be one but okay yeah I have so
many games installed that I'm like
there's nothing else I want to install
on this thing because this is gonna have
so much storage
well that's awesome
um any any other thoughts anything else
that you want to share about time with
the steam deck I guess the one thing to
keep in mind is uh it's not so much
that's walled off it's just the support
isn't there for certain games and things
like game pass that I think will be
perfect for steam because there's some
compatibility in software issues that's
getting in the way of its full potential
but that's going to get resolved over
time what it is capable of doing now is
still more than enough if you just play
games on Steam all that's there all your
Cloud saves on whatever games you have
it's all just readily available so it's
I can't imagine it doesn't up getting
some sort of Xbox app definitely
definitely it's a good question someone
else can steam deck run OBS for gameplay
recording
yeah I mean it's a PC so well not for
not in that way I don't believe for
gameplay recording but you can run over
yes you know yeah use it as a PC so
absolutely yeah you can go to desktop
mode if you hold down a power button
there's an option to go to desktop mode
and if I believe there's a Linux version
of OBS and this this is just a Linux PC
that's all it is so if it runs on Linux
it it can do it as long as it it's not
like too power hungry I guess but the
steam deck is plenty powerful yeah very
cool
um okay hard pivot how did everybody
feel about not E3 uh I guess the first
thing was summer game Fest Xbox was
second
um anyone have any uh impressions of
Summer game first feels like it was so
long ago now but it was a million years
ago yeah I know yeah like any standouts
Calista protocol is the game
yeah same oh yeah that's a video game
ass video game yeah regular old that's
like hey if you [ __ ] about video games
all the time play this one it's exactly
what you want and there's [ __ ] about
that space you're all the debt
everything is now Dead Space
video games yeah yeah
um I'm trying to look up what else even
was announced because I've forgotten
Fort Solace was also summer game Fest
which is interesting because of the
similarity between the two it seems like
they'll be different enough like Ford
Solus keeps being pitched as more of a
thriller than a horror and I don't
necessarily know what that means for a
video game like is layers of fear a
thriller versus a horror does it mean
it's more like that I don't know I don't
know the answer yeah yeah curious to see
but it does seem like it's going to be
kind of short uh more digestible
uh but that was definitely a standout
for me yeah
um they should like Call of Duty uh
aliens Dark Descent Street Fighter six
uh
the awesome nights we got here Jeff
Keeley said Batman is dead Batman is
dead
with that one with a big smile on his
face just just as we always wanted
everybody was waiting for
um I guess like overall I felt like the
the show like I really enjoyed having
devs on stage I saw a lot of like the
community didn't like that
um but I way prefer that like have a
Gameplay trailer but I guess a lot of
them were cinematic trailers
unfortunately but then have people on
stage to elaborate on it I was like that
format I'm a huge fan of personally yeah
I agree I really liked it the
unfortunate thing was the big sort of
finale which was The Last of Us Part One
remake got leaked by Sony itself right
yes um which like what they just posted
someone posted a tweet or something I
missed yeah I think somebody tweeted a
trailer or something the the trailer and
then they didn't know listing wasn't it
like a store
that posted early on their YouTube
channel
who knows yeah whatever it was it
happened
um what else did we get Street Fighter
six I feel like that was yeah before
they showed guile they were like guess
who's a new character and it's like
guile awesome yeah you look sick though
at uh yes what do you think yeah
um I mean I'm not a straight I'm not a
fighting games guy so my opinion doesn't
count for [ __ ] I like I'm like hey this
looks like Street Fighter and I enjoyed
playing it that is honestly the extent
of my uh experience with it it was funny
though because I think I told this story
before but like I did some
over-the-shoulder filming for um the
game and uh I was like asked the Capcom
guy I'm like hey do you mind if I just
like do this and post it on social media
he's like yeah man go for it I'm like
sweet so I just like played a game with
Chun Lee and then I posted out some dumb
tweet like hey Street furniture
and then that just that tweet just went
crazy because it turns out that was the
very first like the gameplay that had
gone out for Street Fighter anywhere all
right and so all these like fighting
game blue check marks were retweeting it
and I'm like guys I don't know anything
about Street Fighter I'm really sorry
tell us about the frames and how many
frames questions does it have this does
it have I don't [ __ ] know if it has
that it has a Chun Lee
yeah that's so funny I I also played it
and like I loved how colorful it was I
thought that was really cool
presentation was awesome yeah I played
the simplified mode forgetting when it's
called
um which is very similar to what Mortal
Kombat has said in the past and the
thing that I found interesting was that
I asked the team and I was like what's
gonna happen for online multiplayer
and they said that
in theory everyone will still be able to
play like if you're playing on either of
those different gameplay modes you would
still be ranked the same way but that
they think it'll actually be easier for
competitive players who are playing on a
traditional uh controller layout or uh
input um that they have more control
literally because they can use more
inputs thus it will actually be easier
for them not harder
um but he also wasn't super confident in
that so I want to note like that PR guy
was like I'm pretty sure so not 100
clear on if you'll actually be able to
play competitive uh without it being
split but that's what they said at the
time so I think it's great that they're
adding that accessibility feature
because so much fighting game to me I I
what I like about fighting games and why
I like Super Smash Brothers more than
any other fighting game is that it's
more about like reading the opponent and
less about oh my God how do I do the
move use forward a or you know neutrally
or whatever it's like very simple inputs
and they're kind of Super Smash Brothers
fine Street Fighter a little bit so that
newcomers can just like go into it with
the mindset of like what moves do I need
to execute right now instead of like how
do I execute the moves yeah and then
over time they can learn how to like
properly do the thing but in the
meantime it can just get into it uh with
simple inputs but still having to know
like how to read the opponent what moves
to execute and that that is the fun of
fighting games to me it's definitely
like wonderful for accessibility
especially for people who've never
played fighting games I think that I
actually found it a little bit harder
because I kept wanting to go to default
things that I already knew sure and I
was like wait a minute this is what am I
supposed to do to get this to work this
way
um but generally yeah it seemed like
it'd be really easy for players to pick
up and it doesn't seem like it'll have
any negative impact on the fighting game
Community which yay but also
as Ralph said I don't know [ __ ] about
fighting games I'm just doing my best
correct yeah don't understand what's
happening they all look great really
like Soul Calibur that's my hot take I'm
with you guys something I'll always be
my favorite
main old time very good oh yeah so uh
yeah that's that's what those are my
that little stabby pole um
I was uh Sophia and Nightmare nice but
like a sexy nightmare sexy nightmare
when he had like the long hair and know
how much
hot nightmare yes very good it's hot
wasn't yoshimitsu from Tekken Yeah Yeah
from Tekken and you could spam it he had
that stupid thing where he's where he's
on his sort of like a pogo stick oh yeah
yeah I also remember link was in Soul
caliburg yeah
yes it was specifically for Xbox which
was so weird it was like McFarland spawn
it was like all like it was like he did
like a new drawing for him it was
awesome yeah so that was really cool oh
man Soul Calibur you know what a time
this is the Dreamcast days when like
because I remember seeing Soul Calibur
on the Dreamcast for the first time
being like it is impossible that any
game could look this good what is this
this has to be fake it's not possible
Right my brain could not comprehend how
good Soul Calibur on the Dreamcast I
remember first time I started at Harvey
Norman when they had a demo wasn't Dick
Smith I remember uh like playing Project
Gotham Racing 3 and being like this is
real this is this this just looks like
real life
Project Gotham Racing but we are talking
about current video games not Project
Gotham Racing shout out to Kudos
um so I'm a big fan of bluebird team
I've played every single game that
they've ever made it's not that I think
they're all tens but it's like I will
play every game they ever make and I
still don't actually know what layers of
fears is but that's a game that they
announced that I believe oh that's right
a combination of the two layers of fear
games together
I know some things about it but I don't
think they've gone like right I'll tell
you guys after okay I don't know what's
public what we have is a new game built
upon the foundations of layers of fear
layers of fear inheritance and layers of
fear too with surprising historian
gameplay Direction so oh okay that's
never mind that's what I know
okay so it's like layers of fear remix I
think
yeah I haven't played any of them so
Ultra Deluxe exactly yeah they're just
like kind of like atmospheric pseudo
Thriller slash horror experiences like
is it just basically like the medium but
a different story
way cooler than the media not at all
like the medium yeah that's a very like
unusual game for them that
um I mean yes but the big thing about
layers of fear that I think makes it
stand out from other horror game series
is generally that the environment
changes around you constantly so you
know how like Resident Evil you have
that safe space in a safe room it's very
rare that you ever feel safe in layers
of fear because you can walk down a
hallway and then know that when you turn
around everything's gonna look
completely different and you don't know
what's going to be behind you and it
just does there's a lot of layers of
time that's kind of cool so much yeah
all right and that's it all I know about
Bluebird is the medium and that
apparently rumor has that they might be
working on a silent to Silent Hill 2
remake they might be at a studio that uh
konami's uh licensed that out for
everyone's really pissed about that
people really hate with the team yes
really really oh yeah yeah you don't
know you haven't heard about all this
stuff yeah they have something
controversies oh do they yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I don't wanna no idea yeah
it's it's the there's a lot of stuff
about their treatment the way they
handle mental health issues in their
games I know the medium was
controversial
um
which I understand they definitely
approached a topic that I feel like a
lot of Studios would not
and I don't know that they nailed the
landing
um no I don't think they had
almost like a team that was insensitive
no exactly and I think that's why I yeah
exactly so I kind of cut them some slack
as well because I'm like okay yeah
probably didn't manage this the best way
possible but like at the same time I
don't think you were trying to go out
there to big dicks and like you know
what I mean which counts for something I
know a lot of women don't like Blair
Witch which they also made sure the VR
version was cool but the main thing just
kind of didn't like it was like you had
the you had the Blair Witch license you
could have done anything and we did
mostly spend time walking around lost in
the woods which like yes but also not
that fun in a video okay the dog in a
radio nice dog very cute dog sometimes
interesting radio yeah I mean like I
said I don't think they make 10 out of
10 games but I will always play a blue
bat Team game because I feel like yeah
creative in ways that I never expect so
I'll play it whatever the [ __ ] it is I
will always play them
um fair enough but I don't I don't know
that I buy that they would ask bloopa
team to make Silent Hill 2 remake I
don't they they've said that they're
working they've popped they publicly
said they're working with canal
yeah it's very clear that they're
probably working on something Silent
Hill related yes
that yeah they've entered into a new
partnership with developer and publisher
Konami holy [ __ ] yeah the the rumors are
that there's a new Silent Hill gaming
Development A Silent Hill 2 remaster and
also like a Silent Hill
stories thing like yeah in that world
you know downpour too
second all right
I did hear about the Annapurna one yeah
but I would I wouldn't have chosen
Bolivia team to do a Silent Hill 2
remake well again I don't know if
they're doing the Remake per se they
might be just working on the Wall Street
stories or they might be doing they're
not doing I'd be very surprised they're
doing Silent Hill three like stunned
um but interesting whatever the next
Silent Hill Mainline entry whatever you
want to call it but um yeah I don't know
man it's uh
it's it's weird it's surprising that
Konami is even really doing that at this
point because they just they make so
much money off Pachinko that I I think
that I've built up and yeah yeah as a
huge Silent Hill fan I think that I've
just convinced myself that it's never
going to happen until it does happen and
I'm like I don't buy it it's not they're
never making another one and if they do
it'll suck anyway I don't care I don't
want it they're good it's weird they're
they're back in the game it doesn't yeah
it's very weird like it's it's funny the
I'm the opposite as like a metal gear
fan I'm like no I don't need any more no
just stay the same way stay quiet you
know that could be silent hill could use
more but
yeah oh man yeah I I still would love to
see a remake of one of the older metal
gear games or something like that but
yeah I don't know if I want a new entry
new podcast let's let's go let's do it
let's do it I think they still hold up
pretty well but uh so Konami did get
into nfts and I know made like
yeah and not insignificant amount of
money they didn't make a ton but there
was an auction for a Castlevania nft
that was a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
something like that yeah
um there was I did those Collectibles
yeah
celebration anniversaries exactly it was
the 35th Anniversary or something I
don't know which like I hate but um yeah
and they seem to have used possible
every time you need a pack of stickers
in the mail yeah seriously you have them
that's the appeal yeah it's just yours
these stickers
um storm gate was definitely one that a
lot of people are excited about that's
from the blue X blizzard RTS pizza oh
that's right it looked like Starcraft
and Diablo had a baby it's like
Starcraft but with like Diablo s
creatures in there as well yeah it was
fascinating yeah that's another one
where they're like we're making it
Korean Starcraft is in my blood so I got
it
this is genetically inclined like
Italians the same with Mario
Italians yeah uh notoriously made in
Italy yeah that's right
company
Italians love Mario it's all they play
that's right
you thought that people pressed buttons
fast and uh
in stock rough you said you should watch
an Italian play Mario it's crazy out
here about 8pm though
um yeah we didn't see a lot about it but
that seemed like one that like
definitely people are excited about uh
Diablo 4 I thought looked awesome it
does look very awesome
um I I was weirdly surprised like I
didn't think it was Diablo for when I
first saw it because the cutscenes did
not look as high production blizzard as
they normally do which could be a good
thing it could be that they like I
wasn't like holy [ __ ] this is most
cinematic thing I've ever seen it looked
a little bit more realistic and I was
like hey maybe that's like good
marketing they did I think they didn't
look as shiny to me as they normally do
no those cutscenes were like in engine
and the fact that they managed to make
the in-engine stuff where Diablo's
usually that isometric but then like the
camera can just like zoom in and still
look that good I think it's pretty
impressive but uh yeah
um Do It um that's true I thought it
looked beautiful I love the art style
um yeah necromance is super exciting
like I'm I'm very excited about it what
do you guys think about having about
Diablo 4 having micro transactions we
gotta think about that I think it's
inevitable it's inevitable and I'm
concerned after I don't think it's going
to be on nowhere close to the level of
immortal but I I can't
trust that it's going to be good enough
or like unintrusive enough because I
I've just that's what I thought the
immortal would be honestly it's a lot of
the early receptions seem really
positive and then launch happens and
then we'll activate I play Diablo model
and loved it and then played it again
when it came out and also really enjoyed
it for the eight hours that I played and
then the stories stop coming out for
people who are like doing [ __ ] that I
wasn't doing and I was like oh my God
holy [ __ ] which sucks because like I
enjoyed playing the game the voice
acting was really good everything was
voiced like it was like a good mobile
game but holy [ __ ] what a what a
disgusting process uh that I don't think
they'll do with Diablo for
because when you're making a mobile game
I guess it is also on PC is kind of the
problem but when you're making a mobile
game you like expect that that audience
is going to expect that
yeah or maybe it's through a different
Market I hope that dialogue doesn't do
that at the very least I I hate that
companies use that as an excuse well
it's mobile so we can get away with how
predatory this is
um and it's just like it's like we have
this line where I mean I don't even
think it's an excuse they're just like
shut up they'll accept it yeah exactly
they're trying to excuse it they're like
no one thinks what they're doing is good
like surely they're like this is kind of
[ __ ] up yeah that'll be fine and the
PPA and it is fine unfortunately because
the people who complain are the
enthusiasts and the majority of mobile
gamers are not the enthusiasts like they
are they're just people oh cool that
looks fun I'll download it sure and then
spend a bunch of money on it on
yeah I don't know I don't really have a
ton of trust in really anything that
blizzard does at this stage which I feel
like probably a lot of people
um agree with but I do think like I
again that the the developer gameplay
Showcase with Diablo 4 I was like
[ __ ] looks beautiful it does look
great I I thought of course don't ruin
it yeah please please just I mean I
guess yeah the difference is
Diablo Immortal is a mobile game yeah
that has a PC Port that's still in beta
Diablo 4 is a PC game that's true you
know that's that's a differentiation
internally surely that they have to
stick to
um yeah yeah I mean I don't I don't
expect they're going to go full pay to
win with it right obviously because I
think that I mean that's just gonna
cause I think too many headaches for
them but I just wonder about things like
you know battle passes that give you
bonus experience an increased chance to
get the legendary set that you want and
all the best cosmetic gear being gated
behind
um you know behind a store or all that
same battle pass or whatever else uh
that is what's and then obviously on top
of that you have to buy the expansions
um I mean I feel like this is a
franchise that has existed for decades
without needing to have Micro
transactions I agree and now it has them
and it's like well everyone's just like
well that's just video games today it's
like well
maybe I don't know I think the problem
Activision Blizzard makes billions of
dollars in profit if they wanted to not
do that they could do that exactly the
problem is Activision blizzards business
structure like blizzard games would
still sell well like Diablo 2 Diablo 3
pre-orders like it would still sell well
but video games have gotten to a point
where well is not good enough when your
competition is FIFA Ultimate Team so
it's like selling well is a failure when
we compare it to FIFA Ultimate Team why
aren't you making that [ __ ] money and
so everything just has to be monetized
out the ass which is like just an awful
reality if I blame FIFA for so many
things yeah and I just wonder what what
um what impact that has on the game long
term because you still have people that
play Diablo 2 to this day and same with
Diablo 3 in fact
um and it's just kind of like their main
go-to game because they can play it and
know that it's all there and that's it
you know when they're happy with that
and I wonder the flip side to that is
with obviously with Diablo uh four is
that they're promising this evolving
live service that's constantly getting
new content and that new content is
funded by the micro transactions okay
well let's just see how that actually
goes before we sort of like say that
that's a you know a Justified excuse or
what have you but um I don't know I just
I definitely think it's going to be a
new chapter for a Diablo
um in a way that we've never seen before
and I am personally yeah not not like
it's inevitable I'm not like I'm not
like oh this is gonna suck but I'm very
much just like let's watch this space
yeah I mean especially after Diablo a
model where I was like oh the mask gets
slipped okay oh you got it back on no
sorry okay cool yeah I hope that at the
very least that the Diablo model
backlash which I almost feel like they
didn't expect people to find because
like I said I played it for eight hours
and I didn't see any of it I did the
worst thing that I had which was very
egregious was I got stuck in a menu that
I thought was required to progress but
it was actually a store
and eyes 28 year old woman was like how
do I progress through where do I go and
then I was like I have to do something
here to get through the story and it was
actually a [ __ ] shop and I was like
you tricked me into thinking this menu I
had to click buttons like there's no way
around that like it was tear and also
God the Cosmetics that looked so cool
were just right in your [ __ ] face and
you're like I'm not gonna buy them I
won't do it but forty dollars Australian
to buy a skin in Diablo and like I've
kind of stopped my using the word I
still use it on occasion by mistake but
I'm like acting like trying to stop
using the word microtransaction because
I just think that is so the wrong word
at this point it's been the wrong word
for a long time right I'm not the first
one to say this but I really feel like
as I was looking at Diablo Immortal I'm
like wow 40 [ __ ] dollars for a skin
in a mobile arpg are you kidding me so
that was a big yeah
do we have a replacement word for
microtransactions like well I just
called spending I just call it in-game
spending now I think that's better um
because I think it's like we're spending
money in games without having to sort of
like suggest that it's actually just
this turning them out when really it's
like hundreds or thousands no micro
transactions is a lie at this point for
sure yeah I say macro transactions at
this point I mean when you're when you
have to spend a hundred thousand dollars
to max out your characters we call it
big horse armor it's horse armor but
more again I tweeted this the other day
I don't know why big tobacco is Big
tobacco and big Pharma is Big Pharma
what about big video game big gamer it's
clearly big video game why don't we just
call it that it's a [ __ ] big video
game it's it's it's a lot I hope that
the Diablo model backlash which again I
don't think they expected
helps Diablo 4 because I think I feel
the same way Ralph I'm not like [ __ ]
this Burn It To The Ground but I am
cautious uh yeah I'm done so it's
interesting because we talked about this
on our thing uh uh on FPS how it's it's
almost like with the whole Diablo
Immortal backlash that happens back when
it was first announced the whole like oh
you guys don't have phones or whatever
and then everybody was so pissed and
then they went dark
and then they came out with the game and
the game was uncompromised like they
didn't it's like they didn't tone back
anything like I thought there was going
to be like a mobile game yeah some
clever uh you know trade-offs or
compromises but it was just like
unashamed full ass Diablo micro
transaction stuff yes it is it is by how
Diablo it is in that like again
everything's voiced yeah it looks good
the combat's fun fun to play with
friends most games off
but they just out the ass like just like
this is our time mobile game free to
play and I like I said I I think that
companies will use that as an excuse I
don't think that ever should be an
excuse and and I really do hope that one
of these various governments keeps
talking about potentially cracking down
on loot boxes and microtransactions
actually does yeah at the very least I
look towards uh like I like Rod Ferguson
and and he's leading up with with Diablo
4 and like I'm just a fan of his kind of
like you know it seems like his track
record his resume of like leadership of
like coming in and writing projects like
writing the ship
so to speak seems it seems like it often
works out like a creative like Rod has
any business say in a company like
Activision Blizzard yeah that's where
I'm naive I have I have no idea yeah
yeah
I'm sure he would fight for things
that's that's the good news
um it's got to be really complicated for
the people who are there who love
working on Diablo like to like their
people on Diablo model who love working
on that game that's like yeah I don't
know what I would do like I don't think
that I would it but that's like to say
we'll just quit is like you've got to be
in a massive position of privilege but I
think that they would be like God of War
Ragnarok full of micro transactions I'd
be like I don't know that I want to do
this yeah not a good one the other thing
is well what I've experienced recently
is like this is very much changed the
way I plan to cover mobile games so for
example like I did a preview for Diablo
Immortal I'm like hey this looks cool
you know I was just like I played it and
I'm like this looks like a cool thing
and I'm like hey the microtransactions
are probably gonna suck but like you
know overall this is a pretty fun Diablo
game and I'm looking forward to playing
some more of it we'll see how the
microtransactions go turns out the
microtransactions were many orders of
magnitude worth than I ever could have
predicted I will never do it again I
will I will never promote a mobile game
ever again so I so I got a approach from
Ubisoft recently and they were just
telling me about the existence of the
division mobile game right and they were
like just FYI and you know you can do
whatever you like with this and I'm like
okay cool could you tell me about the
in-game spinning stuff and they're like
oh we're talking about that stuff later
on and it's like well
I'm not going to cover your game until I
know how you're going to charge for it
do you know what I mean because it could
be like hey and the division mobile game
looks pretty cool to be honest with you
it kind of looks like a division one
port but like expanded and it's pretty
like impressive right so yeah I was like
this looks really cool I would love to
pop pump this as in like get some word
out like I love the division it'd be
cool if this franchise continues to
exist and that's that's awesome but I
can't I don't want to do that until I
know how they're charging for it you
know what I mean and because otherwise
it's like well I've set up people to get
excited about something only for them to
be charged out the ass so I'm definitely
you know kind of just taking a big step
back on all that stuff and I'll I'm not
pretending it doesn't exist like I
shattered out in my new show for example
I'm like hey by the way this is coming
but let's not get too excited until we
know you know
um yeah which it sucks like it'd be nice
if you could just see a game and be like
hey I'm excited for this game but you
have to be like hey I'm excited for this
game but also they could try and charge
you fifty thousand dollars to play it so
let's just you know pump the brakes yeah
I mean I think any any developer who
says oh the monetization stuff does not
affect the design is is it's it's
[ __ ] like on some level it always
will make some more severe than others
but on some level it has to affect the
design because the store can't there's
no point in the store existing if there
isn't some incentive for people to go
there
um and and yeah and Diablo moral
especially like the end game is what
people stay uh for uh when it comes to
Diablo
um the campaigns will get some started
right so it's like
it's very clear what they were trying to
do there and I mean it's even like free
to play skate right like what do you
guys think about free to play skate it
also scared me it was like oh
yeah
so
something free to play I feel like I'm
afraid of at this point like and the
fact that they called it just skate was
like oh no no
yeah right I love that they released
that early gameplay footage like I wish
that more Dev Studios yeah that would
they release something that's clearly in
progress and everyone goes this looks
like [ __ ] and then you go but that's how
it works and I like I wish that people
were more transparent about that stuff
that got me excited and then they're
like it's free to play and it's not
called
Escape four or yeah it's funny it's like
if if someone came up to me like if if I
didn't like pay attention to this stuff
if someone came out hey do you want to
play Tony Hawk's Pro Skater forever
I would go oh yeah that's awesome so the
same thing with skate but it's like just
knowing how the environment is you go oh
no you can't help but go oh no anything
live service as well it's yeah
we saw this with Halo like obviously
it's cool that lots of people get to
enjoy Halo you know
Halo experience sure but the what we
lost in that process I think it's been
good you know what I mean like it's and
I'm not talking about the lack of
content updates I'm talking about the
fact that to unlock the stuff that you
want it's now you know forty dollars to
unlock a set of armor or whatever else
and it's like well has has that been
worth that transition I don't think I
also didn't really notice it playing
Halo infinite because I didn't care
about that stuff but same token like I
didn't know how much anything was worth
because I never even looked same token
though it was so cool playing like retro
Halo 3 or whatever else and seeing the
guy with the cool helmet and knowing it
was because he earned it and that
doesn't apply anymore right look at this
[ __ ] guy oh my God that would have
been so hard to get and now it's like
okay you you spend time that's right
it's a shame the only micro transaction
I bought in the last decade is a dog and
sea of Thieves
and I stand by my decision
what's fair yeah this is this is what
what like there's so much about gaming
these days where the highs are some of
the highest but the lows are some of the
lowest ever and it it's become such a
Minefield where you're always paranoid
about what if this game becomes the next
ex former game that just completely
screwed everything over and it didn't
used to be this way and I used to look
forward to EA Games and UV soft games
and the worst thing I had to worry about
was is this gonna is this game gonna be
for me and is it going to be polished
those are like basically the two things
I had to worry about but now it's just
like something looks amazing the
developers put their hearts and souls
into it but one management decision
about monetization or you know whoever
makes those decisions that can just [ __ ]
up the gameplay Loop so much that all
that work the developers put into just
lovingly crafting the game it almost
feels like it goes to waste because the
loop is as important as the mechanics
themselves the loop is what keeps you in
you know engaged I hate that word now
um but it's what keeps you like coming
back uh it's it's and and when that Loop
is constantly interrupted by hey you
can't progress any further hey pay up
it's no longer it loses the purpose of
fun positions really bump me out I know
right I know I know
someone's mentioning Star Citizen in the
chat you want to go down that rabbit
hole
nine thousand dollars ship baby that's
let's go
um okay let's jump to something
potentially less depressing maybe before
I start ranting about capitalism
Jake hold on someone hold him back he's
gonna do it again uh hideo announced a
new project with Xbox that um
specifically referenced the cloud and
Cloud technology
um I don't know what that means but I
did ask a number of people who you know
work in game development in a way that
they're much more informed on what the
[ __ ] that means than me and they all
said they're paying him a lot of money
think oh my God it's just gonna be like
a stadia game which no that's not what
it is I just think everything's like
Cloud it's just it
flight simulator employs Cloud
technology to render the planet so it's
like there's stuff like that where Cloud
technology isn't just about streaming
games on your phone it's like the tech
itself can be used to pave the road to
fascinating new ways of you know
Graphics rendering or you know gameplay
design whatever Kojima might be coming
up with he said I've always wanted to
make this game and now the technology is
here to make it I don't know what that
means but I feel like he's not just
gonna make a game that's traditional
that is on the cloud he's going to
leverage that technology somehow to go
for something weird and interesting I'm
excited whatever it is interestingly
This Cloud technology discussion was
happening at like the start of the Xbox
One era right that was one of the
biggest promises of that where they said
that you know Crackdown 3 for example
and the the basic promise was that a lot
of the local processing that would have
happened on your own Hardware is
actually happening in the cloud and then
elements of that can then be beamed into
your game so to speak and beams are
shitty you can like boom a word but like
that's ultimately it right it's just
somewhere else
somewhere else and then you get the
benefits of it on on your screen right
and that's an awesome idea like why
hasn't that been leveraged more and a
flight simulator does do that yeah just
said it uses Azure to stream in like all
the all the map data and stuff got high
and played that and was like I gotta
make something like this man
again from everything I heard for
everyone I also like they paid him to
say this he got a lot of money to say
this however
I don't know based on Kojima and Kojima
Productions in general I cannot imagine
him working on a project for money that
didn't also creatively excite him yeah I
don't know what that means but I just
can't ask Monster Energy plot
replacement that's that's how you get it
he just really likes Monster Energy okay
it's like the only time I see stuff like
that and I go that's not advertising
I was like he's just a huge fan there's
no way I mean to be fair when Norman
Reedus and AMC ride comes up and the
Motorcycle starts playing while Norman
Reedus is taking a [ __ ] it's kind of
funny it's like it's an ad but it's kind
of kind of funny the way you implemented
it we're all right we're all right with
it yeah I don't know it's it's an
interesting one because like yeah we
don't really know what it means we don't
know how it's going to be utilized and I
guess that's the exciting part
potentially sure
I do hate the conversations among like
PlayStation fans oh Kojima betrayed us
and all it's like he's not on the side
of the platter he just likes making
games independent company man yeah
exactly it's cool that he's partnering
with all these different companies and
he's still you know working on I mean
Norman Reed has blurted out death
stranding too so that's happening yeah
um so that's probably gonna be very Sony
tied so you know it's like he's working
on multiple things I think it's cool I I
can never understand why you would not
want people on multiple platforms to
have access to creativity but uh you
know that's just me
um yeah so don't know what it means
hopefully it'll be cool and hopefully
Microsoft did pay them a bunch of money
that sounds great get paid
um otherwise we got Resident Evil
Village DLC which I thought looked
really good and in that period of time
obviously a big
um big talking point was the Resident
Evil 4 remake uh how does everyone feel
about that one
it does look good all right we got to
see more but man it's giving me the the
feels I mean that was a special game
when it first came out when I first
played it so to see it and that Graphics
Fidelity is it's kind of exciting I mean
you right we knew that was good yeah we
knew yeah we knew for a while it's
rumored I believe but even before being
rumored just logically yeah it did
technically announce it a while back
they were like yep we're doing it yeah
yeah that's true you're right also one
of the most released games like it's a
sky release yeah oh yeah that's right
pretty much on everything I just uh
played it on on Oculus and it's [ __ ]
awesome on Oculus so I hear it's super
fun like there are so many cool things
with like reloading or like pulling a
grenade out like just the way that they
do it and that game in particular is
it's so much fun it's so cool it's
awesome it's a really fun it's a fun
situation to be in because it's like
waiting around for the Resident Evil 2
remake if you played the original you're
like a remake of that wow what's that
gonna be like where with four now we
we've seen the blueprint we've seen like
the direction they take with these
remakes so it's almost like now you have
more room to be like so for me
personally I've come to grips with
accepting this remake where it's like
they can't capture that weirdness
lightning in a bottle twice and I don't
think they should try as much as they
say that like oh we're going to be
faithful to the original
there's some things that are just not
going to translate over the same way
yeah so it's like I'm looking forward to
a new interpretation of this like how I
would read a Batman book and Batman's
like this in one comic book and Batman's
completely different in another comic
book I'm like let's let's see how this
is I mean just from the trailer it's
darker it's a little more spooky area
because cool that's not that scary I'm
into it no not at all yeah a couple
parts but yeah it's more sort of towards
the beginning it's more tension driven
and it goes back to Crazy towards the
end I mean which is I guess all of
Resident Evil when you think about it
like even two like the way it ends I
mean finding a giant glob of Flesh with
your rocket launcher at that point true
yeah that's pretty ridiculous with the
one-liner what does he say like sayonara
a [ __ ] oh yeah I don't remember what he
says God's being Spiderman
whether it needs to be remade and I keep
finding that conversation very strange
because I'm always like well if you
don't want to buy it just don't buy it
like yeah like if you don't want to play
it again just don't play it again like I
feel like that across the board I'm
excited about it because in my head a
similar kind of what you're touching on
that Jake I look at Resident Evil 4 as
two parts and that like I have the
original resume before which I can play
on a million different platforms
basically the same and then this and I
feel like I can enjoy both separately
it's not like the new Resident Evil will
completely replace re4 which still plays
relatively well again especially on
Oculus it's super fun I'm just like give
me a new update to it I'll totally take
that like I'm I'm happy to have it I'm
happy to keep having it give us Code
Veronica just keep doing it yeah I look
at it as like if you if you guys you you
budding developers taking this crap a
new generation taking a crack at
Resident Evil 4. if you can nail or
outdo the opening of the original
Resident Evil 4 then like you can do
anything so like that's really the bar
for me if I start the game and that's
that the opening kicks ass
I'm like I'm gonna be really impressed
because that's like one of the most
incredible things ever made in video
games I think definitely I think that um
it's really interesting
the growth of Resident Evil as well
because when they announced re7
biohazard I was like Ugh this doesn't
look like Resident Evil I know not my
Resident Evil I don't want it and then I
played it and I was like bro this is
sick this is actually sick and then they
keep doing it and a lot of people have
the same reaction to re2 they're like if
this isn't my re2 and then like this
good [ __ ] slaps dude
I'm happy about it to a degree I think
God of War had some of that where it was
uh yeah I did that to his face I was
like oh really I don't buy that the
combat's gonna be good I just I'm not
sure about it he was like it is
elevated I think with the the re-release
um both from just the way they represent
Kratos as a more three-dimensional
character to the comet itself is also
freaking awesome like I love the combat
of God of War yeah it's different but
it's still very good yeah it's still
very good I agree
um shall we jump to Xbox Bethesda
showcase which I thought was interesting
that they started to approach that with
uh games coming out in the next 12
months how do you guys feel about that
strategy like do you think fantastic
yeah I dig it personally okay big fan it
was um almost every single game which I
guess also confirmed that uh I'm
forgetting the name of it Hollow Knight
that was a big one yeah that's right so
okay
yeah we'll see about it at least they
didn't have the date or the year or no
and that was before she said I got at
least a window yeah it's so funny yeah I
wonder how many of those things are
going to be delayed hopefully yeah
that's the yeah uh but overall I thought
it was a really fun conference like I I
definitely really enjoyed it I
appreciate that approach and the
transparency with it
um how do you guys feel about the
redfall gameplay
I I uh I love the Synergy of like the
different powers and weapons I think
that looks fun
um the tone of the game is what's
throwing me off because it started off
with this like very kind of uh spooky
kind of uh suspense driven kind of tone
and then it became very like ah we're
all just joking around now and I I like
that initial tone better of like
vampires and it's all spooky and thrill
based I wish they would have leaned more
towards that but uh gameplay looks you
know like being a good co-op left for
dead style experience super powers yeah
hmm
yeah yeah I'm not really investing too
much into it other than that like I like
the the the the town the New England
town and like the the haunted vampire
like fall thing does seem very much like
a like an aesthetic that Arcane would do
really well just seems like a natural
step for them that's what I'm most
excited about I'm at the point now where
I watch Arcane trailers and they edit
their trailers so sick where it's like
you're doing trick shots and you're
ollieing over an enemy and doing a click
pow and then like there's a power and
I'm like I I played death Loop and I'm
like okay I'm gonna do that like death I
didn't do anything cool
I love Arcane I loved death loop I love
prey I love this on it this is like the
first time that one of their games has
not appealed to me a ton and I don't
really know why multiplayer
yeah I mean I personally did not enjoy
death Loop
um for a variety of reasons I think I
really loved that obviously Arcana the
immersive Sim studio and I really
support their desire to want to move
away from that type cast and like Flex
their creative muscle elsewhere 100
support that happy for them love that
they get to do that founder who's the
reason they were like that left and made
his own Studio correct correct correct
but selfishly I'm just like I just want
pray too yeah I don't really want
another one of these like Co-op shooter
things I like Co-op Shooters don't get
me wrong uh like some of them could be
great but um I kind of just want Arcane
to make more prey yeah yeah that's
that's again purely selfishly and I know
that that's not the right Club but
that's why I'm not personally like
really looking forward to this I had the
same sort of response to that did you
see that Hyena's game that was revealed
from creative assembly the guys that did
Alien Isolation before no see this is
the thing that face no one's heard of
this game right the team who made alien
in isolation that create that creative
assembly instead of making alien
isolation 2 which would have been
incredible they're making something
called hyenas which appears to be
another like competitive Co like team
shooter hero shooter thing and it's kind
of just like IGN six out of ten they
couldn't come back
Brian McCaffrey
um
yeah I know right but if that's the
thing where it's like okay I really love
that you guys get to make whatever you
want then that's fun but I really want
alien isolation too yeah I really don't
want another hero shooter like I just
we've got enough of them you know what I
mean yeah that's where I'm at with
redfall I'm also kind of burnt out on
like
quirky like four player quirky character
designs where they're all starting to
feel the same and I can't remember them
yes and then couple that with the fact
that like I these games are like I know
you can play this game single player but
these games are made for people that
have like that group of friends that
like they rotate and they keep playing a
new game I don't have that I'm like
totally utterly
completely alone alone so I'll play it
with you Jake okay
how many you know how many of these you
know I don't know the ridiculous thing
is that I will play all of them
obviously it's a little bit different
because it's on Game Pass I will play
all of them for five hours have a good
time when I do that and then just bounce
and I feel like that's how I feel about
redfull is like I'm going to play it
I'll probably have a really fun time
playing it because everything's fun when
you play it with friends I don't know
how long I'm going to play it and I am
looking forward to Hands-On previews
coming out to get some more impressions
of what it is because yeah again I love
Arcane I really really love what they
make redfull just hasn't grabbed me
because of that multiplayer aspect
do you guys see what uh Dana Nightingale
who is the campaign director at Arcane
said I think like uh yesterday
um if it seems like they're kind of
stepping back from making more linear
driven more linear campaign style games
and stuff like that because of you know
like death Loop just didn't take off
like they wanted to I guess I'm not sure
but it seems like I'm just stepping away
from I don't know what the reason is
they said this a while back they said
they were moving away from the immersion
team genre they said this probably two
plus years ago they said okay we're
gonna move move Beyond it yeah what
you're referring to is a rocket paper
Shot Rock Paper Shotgun interview yeah
yes uh they may never make a linear
campaign like this on it ever again yeah
yeah
um which is like such a bummer yeah and
like Dana's the person who made
Clockwork mansion and [ __ ] like it's
like keep making those please like those
to happen yes so good I don't know yeah
she has threads on like how some of the
game design of certain missions started
where she just like posts pictures of
like here's what this level originally
looked like and what it came into and
it's like it's so cool to watch I love
the way they design things like yeah big
big fan of Arcane but
it is a shame although again just sort
of current trends so again it's
something that I'll play it's on game
plus I'll play it I'll probably have a
fun time playing it but it yeah it's not
something I'm super excited about I
don't know maybe a little surprises I
hope it does exactly all right so that
to that point briefly you started to
come back to this one that Jake said
about like the characters and the
setting and whatever like the zany
characters you get kind of a bit tired
of like I definitely felt that with this
versus something like
um dark tide well I'm a 40K dark tide
which is another Co-op shooter but a
very different vibe and I was totally
into this I'm just like this rules you
know what I mean did you get to play
that yes I did yeah I played a bunch of
it it was super good I loved it I really
really enjoyed that a lot
um what's the other one they're making
bolt gun
yeah I know they're not making that
they're just um I don't believe so
that's no that's just another indie
project but based in the Warhammer 40K
yeah I think that's what I mean it's
just it's another Warhammer oh there's
so many in the works they make so many
games I feel like they just publish
every pitch they get it's questions but
Vulcan looks sick too I was like you put
dude why am I going that's dope I will
play that no that's very exciting yeah
September I did see it at uh summer game
Fest but and I know they had like a
Hands-On thing and Burbank but um I did
not get to play it unfortunately
September's close enough I can wait
um so then the biggest game of show the
entire week in terms of traffic was
Starfield which finally got 18 minutes
of gameplay I think it was
um what were your impressions of
Starfield
I like I like that we're uh a little bit
further removed we're talking about this
now because now that the dust has really
settled I when I first saw it I was like
okay
now after everything is cleared I'm like
ah all right I don't know there's it
just doesn't there's nothing in it that
like jazzes me except for building my
own [ __ ] yeah yeah
um I I remember the feeling I got when I
first watched the Skyrim gameplay reveal
when I first watched The Fallout 4 Game
3 reveal
I'm not getting that same level of I
need this now
um it's just more of a oh cool it seems
like more Bethesda game stuff it seems
like it's very similar in structure but
you can build your own ship and that's
cool and there's space dock fighting and
that's cool but the combat still looks
like creation engine combat a lot of
stuff just looks like you know just
creation engine uh pretty FPS baby if
we're lucky
it's really good yeah yes no man's sky
and no man's Sky yeah games of like like
this have kind of been done or like in
this genre have already been done and
done really good so this doesn't feel as
like unique or a shiny all as it maybe
you would have been had it released
earlier or something but also just it's
a weird one because I think that we all
over hyped it but I don't think they did
that because they were just like it's
coming they didn't say [ __ ] really no no
no that's not true let's not forget Todd
Howard be like oh the the technology for
this doesn't exist yet and now now the
technology exists for Starfield and the
little vidoc things that he's done I
feel like I didn't see any of those oh
yeah they've been here for a long time
it's our first new IP in 20 years it's
like the concept art videos or it's like
here she's a concept art but like I
maybe I'm pulling that from him to be
fair which is like not a great source
that he was on a podcast and he was like
we haven't even released gameplay
yeah and I was like you're right at
least gameplay why am I so hyped about
this so I had a really interesting
reaction to it where at first I was like
oh sick and then in the same 18 minute
chunk I was like oh huh oh and it was so
up and down I'm like another way and I
had to think about it for a few hours
and I was like
okay okay yeah yeah exactly that's me
it's it's okay okay it was a weird
roller coaster but but I think as well
like obviously
Bethesda game studios the way we view
them is so different now versus the wait
because they just had an incredible run
with obviously you had Morrowind you had
Fallout 3 you had Oblivion was a little
bit more mixed in some ways like not the
question but then Skyrim
oblivion's the best no no of course
absolutely and a lot of people say that
a lot of people at no I didn't click
with Oblivion but then Skyrim everyone's
like look on some level everyone
understands that Skyrim magic there was
this was an incredible Studio that had
an incredible run but at the same time
there was lots of stuff under the
surface that we were ignoring with
regards to bugs and all that [ __ ] all
the way through um and and obviously
horse armor in the creation club and all
that stuff but we kind of just filed all
that away but then Fallout 76 came and
it was impossible to ignore any of that
Indie darling for a while even though
they weren't like they were almost seen
that way like Wizards too and now yeah
no with that bubbling darling or a
Delaware darling where are they from uh
Ireland the third star I think it might
be Maryland yeah
right
um but with that bubble popped I think
the entire narrative around Starfield
changes you know it's like I don't think
it has that same level of blind hype and
excitement because
yeah we're all a bit more gun shy now
and I think as well we've really
understood the limits of that creation
engine which I think exists in this way
so that it can fit for the modern
Community which is fine by the way I
actually understand that Todd Howard is
on record saying that you know they love
they're injured because it allows the
modern Community to do its thing and
also because Bethesda is comfortable
with it but the engine is like pretty
dog [ __ ] in a com in a like a you know
contemporary sense if you remove those
that modding and that is the thing I had
been tricked on is that I had read
something that made me think it was a
new engine but actually it's just the
creation engine like with a patch yeah
that's right and they did do that to me
yeah they did they did they did yeah and
it's like it's still I was like oh it
really does look like Fallout in space
uh yeah yeah
Shameless again I don't think it's a
shame per se like I think it's going to
be a cool fun video game and I do think
the magic of many Bethesda games can't
really be captured in a trailer or even
lots of trailers yeah it's very much
about that sense of immersion and the
the the quest lines and the way they
intersect with factions and the choices
you make so I expect it's going to be a
cool ass video game that I'll probably
enjoy but do I think it's going to have
that kind of impact on me that those
other Bethesda games did in the past I
think that's quite obviously we're
framing this negatively but I would say
I I agree that I imagine I will play
through this campaign and I'll have a
great time and I will really enjoy
building ships I will love the No Man's
Sky elements I really like no man's Sky
I will have a good time playing it it
was just a a weird one to watch the
roller coaster of like yeah and it
because they got tied in a console Wars
the hype gets so like contentious you
know yeah [ __ ] annoying is a better
way to put it that it becomes like the
video game to end all video games and it
just I had really thought the community
did that to me but maybe I should look
more into like [ __ ] taught how it said
that I didn't miss because I don't pay
attention to game music it's always
risky [ __ ] Todd Howard said that's a
real name
and it's man like there's so much that's
already just come up
Todd Howard
uh reports suggest Todd Howard neglected
Fallout 76 to focus on Starfield well
that's a bit convenient
all right but did you not hear that did
you not read that quote the the seagull
signal
there's this one line in that article
that says basically the development team
would be like yeah we would call it
seagulling where Todd Howard would fly
by at some point and then [ __ ] all over
someone's ideas and then leave
I tell yes at IGN we called it swoop and
poop where somebody would walk into a
meeting [ __ ] all over it and then leave
we call it the sweep and poop that's
Fallout 76 I guess that's yeah seagull
style um a bunch of people within the
development team didn't want to make
Fallout 76
um or you know when they were assigned
to it they just had a really bad time
crunch everything I mean the whole nine
yards it was not a good development
cycle from yeah what the article reports
at least
a shame
um are they someone in chapter said
aren't they making the Indiana Jones
game I didn't think that was them yeah
they are it's Bethesda softworks again I
do not pay attention no it's not but
machine games it's machine games yeah I
know big Rod Todd is producing so
there's that oh excuse me sorry it's
just things I say just a big Rod Todd
and his cool jacket back at it again
yeah I don't know I like
I don't know why this call is so sad in
particularly I had a great note E3
overall actually yeah like there's even
like those two recent Wolfenstein games
not including Youngblood were so good in
my opinion I love both of them and then
Young Blood I like when I played it and
I realized it was not at all what I even
thought it would be and it's actually
almost like a destiny like without the
appeal of Destiny I was like oh no oh
[ __ ] and it's just in a world where yeah
maybe temperate expectations are good
across the board just everything's sort
of like hopefully it's good again I
think Starfield would probably be a good
game that I would really enjoy playing I
was very impressed by the scale of it
and the amount of things that were in it
that I didn't expect to be in it like
dog fighting I didn't expect that at all
a thousand planets does not appeal to me
whatsoever but I think modders will do
crazy cool [ __ ] with that so that's
definitely cool that they support them
um but yeah it I don't know it just it
was a weird one it was
here
yeah here's what I'll say about
Starfield for me Bethesda games like
they've never played the best they've
not even necessarily looked the best but
it's like once you are in the world and
you're like discovering the different
quest lines and seeing a lot of
different factions yeah The Vibes and
the all the different factions how they
know that's when like I get sold on a
Bethesda game and that's the stuff where
like you can't really convey like Ralph
said in like a trailer or an 18 minute
thing or whatever so I you know who if
the the The Vibes and the story in the
world building is just as Stellar as I
felt you know when I played Oblivion
back in the day then it might just it
might really surprise me and really blow
me away so one of my favorite games ever
like I [ __ ] love fair enough and it's
buggy as hell and it's disgusting and
green for some reason the Vibes
immaculate yeah Oblivion for me like
that that was the first Bethesda game I
got into and uh it's still like yeah
it's janky as [ __ ] in so many ways
but man there's something special about
that game for me that the Great box
storyline you're getting that mask where
uh if you take it off the the guards
stop following you because they don't
recognize you like it has that special
effect and like just just like cool
items like that cool spells you could
you know I don't know it all well that's
ultimately what's keeping me like at
least like I'm just like at least still
paying attention I'm still interested
I'm still gonna check it out because I'm
holding on to like what I was thinking
when they first announced this where or
really when it was first starting to be
leaked was that it's like oh this is
like they've they've done Fallout Elder
Scrolls Fallout like it's been this
cycle and this is something that they
seem like they've clearly like wanted to
make they're making a new thing so I'm
like okay yeah that's that's still the
thing holding my interest the trailer
didn't really do it for me but I'm still
like all right this is something they
definitely want to make and it's
different so and I'll say that they
should not be making the next Fallout
game because Todd has already announced
that after Elder Scrolls they're gonna
make Fallout five and it's like dude let
another Studio make that otherwise we're
all going to be 85 years old by the time
that comes out yeah that's like there
are lots of other Studios yeah there are
lots of other Studios that can do this
so just Farm it out please obsidian
is so small and they're already so
loaded up on projects they're making
four games that's right and there's like
three people that work at obsidious
right so easy it's not gonna happen so
impressive like and all their games are
so uniquely good I'm actually a fan of
obsidian like no idea really what about
is going to be like at this stage I'm
surprised we didn't see more of that I
guess that means it's further away
um don't know what that's actually gonna
play like but that that new game that
they announced uh I don't remember yes
and that's alongside a vowed right is
that yeah that's obsidian and the ground
is hitting grounded human 1.0 and outer
worlds and R2 is coming rounded is
supposedly like very successful for them
it's one of their most popular games
ever oh cool that's great yeah and TV
shows and development yeah that's right
that's interesting super well yeah I
would take an obsidian if they can
manage four games with the team their
size I don't know how they do it yeah
are good yeah the next Fallout game
needs to be like made by like deranged
weirdos because the original the
original Fallout games are just so weird
and wild like they need that energy back
that is the perfect fit for uh like New
Vegas you know I mean Wasteland is
pretty much then it's weird and it also
hasn't really cut through like it's a
cool franchise yeah but if they if they
were to jump onto a Fallout game I think
that studio deserves to have like it'd
be cool if Wasteland was that big
absolutely but the reality is it's not
and it would be cool for them to take a
big project like that and get the
recognition they deserve because you
could even take a story of Western one
and two and then put it in Fallout like
you don't even just it just make it a
Fallout skin remake and everyone would
be like great this is great I love it
Wasteland rules Wasteland three
um
like I would be curious to see how much
that sold
I don't know never finished I feel like
no one talked about it since launch it
was one of my games of the year loved it
um like that year it's a it was one of
the best RPGs I've played in a long time
if anyone hasn't played wastelands free
I really strongly recommend going to
play it because in every aspect it is a
fantastically made game I just feel like
the style of video game does not appeal
to a lot of people no absolutely which
is unfortunate
um so yeah it doesn't look like it
because considering how hardcore it is I
feel like the sales are impressive but
and Game Pass probably helped yeah I
imagine a lot of that is Game Pass
yeah but it's not a tremendous amount no
no no for me Wasteland is one of those
games where like when you Glimpse at it
it doesn't look particularly like wow
inducing but it's only once you really
dive into it and you give it a chance
for it it really unfurls and that's what
it's made of so engrossing it's not
stupid like really great writing like
just so stressful
yes oh the combat is so brutal you're
just like man relax give me a shot like
you load into a combat encounter and
immediately the enemy has made like
eight moves and dropped four nukes on
your head and everyone's drowning
so fast yeah they are really good I
would take them making uh making a
Fallout if that was a thing that was
possible
um what else came out of Xbox but
there's a showcase again star third was
the big one and I feel like
yeah the reception has been pretty mixed
across the board I'm comforted that you
guys feel similarly I was like am I
doing my nuts is this just like kind of
like I'm still excited but yeah
positively leaning mixed but still like
fully on board yeah
but I don't yeah I don't know that it
was ever really gonna live up to the
expectations
um yeah and I don't know if it's like
because it's a new IP and people just
don't know what to expect from because
if it's Elder Scrolls everyone's going
to freak out about Elder Scrolls because
it's [ __ ] Elder Scrolls but I don't
know if that in part has to do with it
and Starfield just uh like from a
Stylistics standpoint looks a little
more generic than I'm used to like
Fallout has such a strong identity you
look at file you know it's Fallout Elder
Scrolls has all these different lands
and Landscapes and uh like races and you
know races and Fantastical environments
and all these things and when you see
Elder Scrolls you know it's Elder
Scrolls star Fields like okay it's like
astronauts okay cool yeah we've seen
astronauts disappointed by the lack of
aliens
because I was like really just a bunch
of humans come on
yeah if I don't get some aliens I can do
a nice kiss on I don't want nothing to
do with it kiss upon
I shall kiss upon you Garris in every
Universe possible
what do you guys think about the whole
thousand planets thing because to me
that feels like a 16 times the detail
kind of marketing thing like it's
probably going to be a thing that's true
but I don't think it's really as big a
deal as they're making it out to be same
as no man's Sky I think it's it's going
to be a bunch of planets that you can
visit that largely have nothing on them
and I think that that like doesn't
appeal to me like I'd worry about it if
it meant that the resources went to
those instead of going on things that I
actually care about have no tangible way
of knowing if that's the case but like I
said before I think it's exciting for
the modding community
that's true it's this big big canvases
that they can just like put scoring
lines so I mean models could have just
built their own planets anyway
they can fix they've been fixing
Bethesda games for years you know so
yeah
yeah it just doesn't mean much to me
yeah it's the point that sounds so they
can they can yell that's all personas
coming to Game Pass and a bunch of
persona coming to Xbox was one of my
like most hyped
I love Persona because I'm so excited
for people who've never played Persona
to get to actually play persona for the
first time since that like if they're
Xbox loyalists for that that franchise
is history that's so cool like it's very
crazy ride and very dark like they they
go all in on the darker themes and stuff
like they don't hold back like yeah dude
those games are [ __ ] up they're dark
yeah they're [ __ ] up yeah
like kind of problematic in some ways
but you know we love them yeah we love
you yeah even
like I don't know why there's a bit
of five where Morgan is like oh women
always so emotional because somebody
tries to commit suicide
yeah yeah oh man what what why was gonna
oh
yeah there's a lot of that [ __ ] um I'm
gonna try to commit suicide for a very
serious reason and he's literally like
women so emotional [ __ ] hell but we
love them
um yeah that one was like definitely one
of my most most excited but like I said
the game I'm
most anticipating is Callisto protocol
and then the game that I feel like I'm
guaranteed to love is for sure metal
helsinger I think like no matter what
when that comes out I'm going to love it
just play it yeah yes I played the demo
huge fan but I think like it could have
a potential of um ending up a little bit
too much like Doom 2016 which like I
also love but Corridor big room Corridor
big room Corridor big room so it's hard
to say what the other levels will look
like
oh
one that I'm really excited about is
Arab and Shadow Legacy it looks I don't
know if you guys remember that one it's
like it almost looks like Assassin's
Creed but it's like you have Shadow
Magic and like move yeah shadows and uh
I love stealth games and that looks like
you know it's gonna maybe
um fill that void that I feel like
stealth has just kind of been
hibernating as of late I feel yeah and
Assassin's Creed really no longer feels
like a stealth game to me no it's not
getting started yeah yeah Urban Shadow
Legacy feels like it's that it's
Assassin's Creed with like metal gear
it's like cyberpunky because it's got
all these mechs and robots and
everything but with Shadow Magic it was
awesome uh the there's this uh um uh
lovecraftian uh uh metroidvania called
the last case of Benedict Fox that I
thought yeah that's high on my list that
looks incredible yes I love how that
looks what is that on
PC thing yeah that did look like
obviously very inside limbo real messed
up yeah that looked uh beautiful looking
game there was some things yeah some
announcements games that I hadn't heard
of or seen before that I thought looked
very very cool for sure that I am now
not remembering the names of because
they are new IP which is unfortunate
right but yeah it was there was a lot of
variety I felt like definitely clearly a
year where a lot of things were horror
inspired that that seemed to be a pretty
recurring theme but I am all right with
it I'm okay with that yeah pigtail looks
great very excited for that yeah finally
excited to see if scorn actually
releases us here and what the hell it is
like how it plays yeah because it looks
gross which is cool for so long what is
it yeah who knows yeah who knows man wow
visually fascinating but yeah visually
fast it seems troubled it's what I heard
development like what is the combat it's
like you grab your like weird like
aliens like your stomach and then you're
like I'm gross like that's the whole
game like I I have no idea maybe yeah
that's planned for October I think yeah
yeah I look forward to playing it if
that is the case
um and then we had a couple of things
that happened after E3 Skull and Bones
um
like I was very interested in and then
like quickly plummeted but in a way that
I feel like there will be an audience
for that game it's like a World of Tanks
or a World of Warships sure people who
are into that will be into it but I was
like very disappointed that you know you
can't actually walk around on your ship
that you can't get off your ship I was
expecting it to be a lot more like Black
Flag yeah like it just lacks the pie
like I like Pirates and I was watching
that and I was like boring oh my God
like and the problem is too is that they
took a lot of time detailing the the
shops the loot the progression just the
general Loop but like it's so boring to
see that in a presentation where it's
like every game has that now so it's
like you have to play it and get engaged
in that Loop to see if it actually but
like to be complete you have already
played this like you have already played
it because I played it back in 2018 at
E3 I think I did too you know and it was
the naval combat from Assassin's Creed
it's the same and like the videos that
they showed it's the same like yeah
there's some Rockets or some [ __ ] mixed
in right don't get me wrong but if you
have played that naval combat in those
games it's the same as that so like I
just feel like at least in that game I
can hop off and like put my hood up and
be cool exactly I've played enough of
those oh man I just I don't understand
how this product exists the way that it
does because the Black Flag was
incredible and if you just made like a
sequel to Black Flag like almost like a
spin-off like you've got assassins
Pirates Creed yeah
Pirates Creed and if you just keep that
going like you would have a fantastic
franchise that people I'd be all about
that man I would love yeah
yeah same I put way too much into AC4
and Rogue Gamescom I had this um it's
when I was working for Xbox they put the
game that we had most played and the
hours we'd put into it on our like
Badges and I had like 450 hours in a
sense I didn't even know that it's like
did I fall asleep did you just leave the
game I was gonna say just leave the game
on for like eight weeks but I got really
into the like ship stuff where you I
used smart glass where you'd send your
ships out and you could use the iPad app
that existed for a year it was great
that's true I remember that now yes
that's right yep man all right what a
time so yeah
I still feel like there will be an
audience for Skull and Bones I'm just
not part of that audience like you know
how I said earlier like most multiplayer
games I will play this is not one of
them is it the Sid mirrors Pirates
people like who is it are they still
alive I don't know I feel like it's like
World of War Tanks Bros it's a bunch of
dudes in Russia
you just get really into skull and bones
but like don't forget those keys those
games are all free and I'm gonna guess
this is a 60 like a 60 box product right
I'm gonna guess I don't know that for a
fact yeah but yeah had that barrier to
entry yeah I don't know man I don't know
about that at all Ubisoft games have a
weird habit of sticking with audiences
and they keep like for Honor I thought
was like kind of cool and then I forgot
about it and then for years I just kept
seeing on social media like new for
Honor update hey Community what's up
guys
really engaging like they're really
amazing for it to be fair foreign is
actually excellent so the combat's cool
and and same with Siege like actually
yeah Rainbow Six Siege started out
exactly that way it was so rough it is
good but I dropped off pretty fast I was
like I like this game but also I'm okay
it's a fighting game ultimately and I
think unless you're built for that which
I'm not so I didn't stick with it either
but I played it and I was like hey this
is really cool but yeah yeah it's you
need to be up for that competitive
fighting game it was definitely one of
those ones where when everyone played
for the first week you had a good time
and then people know life did over the
weekend and then on Monday you sucked
yeah I guess that's it for me never mind
I figured out the meta and whatever yeah
yeah but I I do feel like yeah it will
have an audience I just don't think I'm
that audience I don't sure don't think
I'm gonna play much of it and then the
other one is obviously stray came out
this very week yes you all played it yep
I still haven't had I've been too busy
without five hours yes yeah I hope to
finish it like tomorrow or something
steam deck it yeah yeah yeah I loved it
it runs well I'll play it in traffic
we do not condone that don't do that no
please don't yeah I really really
enjoyed it like I was I'm not a cat
person and I was expecting it to be cute
cat game and I was like sure I'm sure
it'll be cute but I actually found it to
be very well designed and endearing and
I really liked exploring the world and
yeah I liked it a lot I think it's
probably gonna end up being a game of
the year Contender for a few outlets at
least so I really I I do agree with that
yeah I mean I think it's interesting
because I I really enjoyed it but Jake I
think you kind of said that you you know
liked it but didn't love it yeah I
didn't yeah uh I I felt like it just it
it was it felt like it was missing an
act
like it's not really like I'm upset
about the length for the price like it's
not really that it's just like how how
the game felt and how how the pacing
went down because it is expertly paced
with how it introduces a mechanic and
then bails on that mechanic and then in
your new setting doing a different type
of thing but it just almost felt like it
was missing like a character moment in
the Middle with one of the that group of
rope that four groups of robots and
maybe like one little ability scene
world I'm just the one with the
waterfall I'm trying to follow anything
right I love that one I should have gone
incredible looking it was really I
wanted to live in that it did look
pretty but I was like guess I'll just
keep climbing okay the only thing is
like I I saw a lot of reviewers and
stuff say that they like
like this story and had like an
emotional impact with it and I felt
nothing and I love cats and I thought
there were some cute moments and and
some good little bits of dialogue clever
stuff good references interesting
questions raised but then it just ended
and I was like Ah that's it all right I
found it to be heartfelt but yes it's
not like I um was super emotionally
invested but I can't find it to be
heartfelt like I was like oh lots of us
I still really really like it and I I
definitely like I'm so excited to see
what they do next Blue 12 specifically
for five years which I feel like is very
obvious again in the design I think the
design in that game is like comes across
to me is very meticulous like it's very
very much coordinated and it like you
said the introduction of mechanics but
then the change like not only a lot of
games managed to pull that off yeah the
only thing that I think is like
particularly unappealing about stray is
the parts where you are using your UV
gun and you just have to back up sort of
over and over again that's the only
option
and that's the only strategy you have
for that that's the only thing that I
was like I could have done with none of
this
I think well I don't know I actually
like those I like but what I was
thinking to myself was oh okay this is
cool it's different I like it but if I
if the rest of the game is this I think
that's going to be a problem but
expertly then they go okay that's gone
and I think that was to that to Jake's
Point look that pacing where they know
when to get on to something different
and then they know when to step off it
you know like and they've just got that
right it's amazing that there's so many
things about it that are so creative
that you it takes a minute to realize
like moments where you're walking around
on the ground through the street and the
camera actually like the the way the
camera is situated is that the cat you
the player are on the very bottom of the
screen and the rest of the screen is
filled by
full-length robots walking down the
street tall buildings and then when you
start going into smaller areas the
camera gets up close and then it gets
stuck on walls because it's a video game
but that like little things that you
don't even think about where there was a
part where I was like oh I can just jump
through that window or I walked up to
some bars like bars on on a door and I
was like oh I can't get through it oh oh
I can't I'm a cat I just squeeze right
through it and like little little things
like that I really appreciated did you
ever walk into any of the robots feet
and make them trip over yeah yeah that's
fine you can do that yeah oh yeah yeah
what you see walking around just like
run into their feet and then the robot
will just like face plant and you get to
stand over them like ah I'm a cat you
work for me now yeah that's great it's
like every dad in the house somewhere
like oh this freaking cat
yeah I was just very very impressed like
I said I it could have coasted by on
being cute cat game but I think it's
actually like a very very well designed
very well directed game from two people
I don't know about that I think it's a
logitechain than that foreign
beats playlist the game oh how good was
this soundtrack yeah oh my God it's so
good yeah dude yeah the musicals there
are parts that sound like the big shell
music from metal gear solid two
so like yeah like where it's like a
little bit of like a Groove to it yeah
like a lounge group I love it yeah the
music was [ __ ] my veins so many
things about it is so good yeah I really
really enjoyed it I was very impressed
by it again you were never gonna pan it
to me with cats I'm very allergic it was
never no I don't like cats either I'm
I'm with you you guys can't come over my
home I used to be a dog person and then
I actually live with a cat and cats are
pretty pretty swayed by cats you
probably get more out of straight than
we did then
it's a good one
um Escape Academy also came out this
week did anyone play that
thank you tonight actually brilliant
love it cool yep why why what what are
you
vibing
it's made by a team who did work on
Escape rooms and then the pandemic
happened and they were like nobody's
showing up to our Escape rooms and so
they just weren't Game Dev uh and made a
video game and I think because like they
clearly think so creatively they're
they're just mechanics to it that a lot
of previous escape room games have just
not been as creative almost like they're
coming from a background of game design
where they're like well did the rules
have to be this way I just feel like
Escape Academy really is its own thing
and is very creative in what it does
um and smart like it's it's
consistently engaging very fun to play
co-op because you know the same way you
do an actual escape room but like other
escape room games like the room I think
it's called
just often are a lot more click until
you find the right thing
um where you can't do that so much in in
Escape Academy and it's very very fun
very good co-op fun I really enjoy it um
also on Game Pass I think as well uh
straight is also on PS Plus
that's pretty good to be honest
uh yeah it's on like the second tier
it's actually kind of hard to describe I
don't know we don't have this difficulty
with game pass but just like it's on
Game Pass but with it with singing with
like oh it's on PS plus free tier but
then premium 10 and the deluxe tier has
like six PS1 games on it and I don't
know man I don't know what's going on it
is weird it's confusing
um and then there was one other thing
that I want to talk about oh yeah as
dusk Falls let me talk about it a little
bit before we went live yeah Jake you
finished it I have not yeah how do you
feel about it
I didn't think I was gonna like it but I
liked it uh it's okay it's pretty cool
cool a lot of the voice acting is pretty
rough yes which I'm sure you noticed
right away yeah I played about an hour
and did feel the slap in the face with
some of the performances for sure yeah
yeah it the one thing that I like though
is that it just told her
told them you know semi-interesting
story it's a little bit different than a
video game story it feels a little bit
more like a like a Breaking Bad or a
Justified type of thing like it's it's a
very like American weird tale about like
a bank robbery and redneck families and
like it actually spans multiple time
periods and
I I thought it was pretty cool and it
was fun to see how it played out
specifically with making the branching
decisions where uh they they really make
you like like I was getting like worked
up like I was like oh hell no and I like
picked the other option or I was like
how could you do that and then I pick it
like I actually like got into it I was
really surprised because I like these
types of games I play all these like
story click this games uh do a qta qte
here type game but this one I was
surprised just how much like the story
was
good all around it was like they came up
with a story first and then they came up
with a video game but then what comes
with that is like
boring qtes and stuff so here's the deal
I said it before I called it mobile game
mechanics which I still stand by which
in one facet is a positive because you
actually can play it from your mobile
yeah uh you can't play touch screen on
your phone which is cool especially for
co-op
yeah it even says like like with the
qtes when it's like press right it says
swipe right and I'm like playing on an
Xbox controller on my couch
but the mobile app thing is really clean
it's very easy to set up to play
multiplayer up to seven people and you
can vote on choices and you can create a
server and it's a code and then you
download the app on your phone you get
in the text is clean the sound effects
are the same on the phone and you just
play uh and it doesn't make you make an
account or anything it's so
straightforward jump in and go which is
how it should be yeah it's just a weird
game for you because it's like a serious
like drama and it's not broken up like
some of the chapters are very long so
it's not like you're having a couple of
beers and you're watching as dusk first
which you can also do that way is like
campy cheesy horror teenage [ __ ] way
better example you'll make fun of it
yes so what's interesting that I'm I'm
starting to come into an issue with is
how so the Quarry had it and this has it
where the QuickTime events and the and
the interactions are really really
really simple so on the one hand I'm
into it for accessibility I think
everybody should have the option to not
[ __ ] play that way if they don't want
to be it because of personal preference
as a consumer or disabilities yeah
totally but uh it just feels like it's
like thrown in as like to keep you awake
where it's like yeah press left yeah
until dawn maybe a hard mode is
warranted until dawn had like you could
die if you moved the controller yeah it
was brutal yeah like you had to just
stay there and not move and like now the
Quarry is just hold that a to hold your
breath for the right amount of time
which is very easy to do yeah it's not
hard at all I remember playing um uh
like you know the older ones like Indigo
prophecy and like that's like a cool
murder mystery game but then in the end
it turns into Dragon Ball Z and like if
you if you miss some of those qte fist
fights in the air like you like you [ __ ]
up and it's like oh no like I oh well
I'll get them next time I guess if I
replay so I like I I like a little bit
more agency with my stuff and as duck as
da as duck as dusk Falls didn't really
have that but I think it just kind of
stuck the story thing
yeah I I was not impressed by the story
at first because the voice acting is off
which is unfortunate some performance is
a good I think some of them are just
it's not not consistent and um the lack
of gameplay I don't play those games I
don't tend to play the like narrative
Choose Your Own Adventure it doesn't
appeal to me at all I knew that seeing
as dust Falls in advance but you saw me
I might play more of it I did want to
try the streaming mode because it's a
broadcast mode where you can give a room
code to your chat yeah they can
influence decisions and I was like
that's cool and that sounds really fun
um I think the decisions are genuinely
good like I watched a streamer like I
clicked around and saw like what
decisions they made and uh like they
felt very strongly about choosing
decisions on something else and I'm like
wow this is good it almost reminded me
of like the hard decisions and like a
totally different type of game like
frostpunk where every decision is pretty
agonizing I was I was I was pretty
impressed that's also player component
reminds me of it's almost like jackbox
party but narrative driven the little
full code it's even like similar yeah
Ralph you were trying to interject
earlier
no I was only trying to ask about um the
multiplayer side do you need to be in
the same place or is it can someone
download some kind of like just that
frame code yep say again just the app I
think you don't that's what I'm saying
yeah so like if if I've but how are they
then seeing what's happening on screen
can they download like a friend pass
kind of thing where they have the client
on their game even though they haven't
been it's a room code so they have to
play your version of the game but that
might just be the broadcast mode unless
there's like a separate co-op mode like
there is in the Quarry
I don't know okay I should actually
probably look at now so it's like you
can play locally on the couch and pair
up controllers and you can pair up the
phone but you can also play on yeah
online I guess two people have to own
the game okay okay
let's have like a friend pass well yeah
I'm assuming that for the broadcast mode
where people just use their phones they
don't have to own the game that would be
nuts yeah so do I actually see the game
on their phones when they're using that
I don't know again I want to try it I
imagine the way we do like is the twitch
stream and then they have input on their
phones yeah
okay do we do Jack boxes somebody
streams it on Discord or something
everyone is on their shows it's very
easy I think to set that up true but
it's cool
especially now that Xbox has Discord
yeah
yeah that's exciting
um
about power wash simulator okay that's
the thing that's gonna happen
four hours yeah yeah it's a lot but
weren't they an amazing four hours Alana
come on admit it you pretend like you
were not enjoying yourself
right I had friends over and I was just
sitting there playing it on mute the
whole time and they were like I need to
[ __ ] leave you're never gonna finish
this playground but the houses I feel
like you guys are very fast yeah they're
good they're a good midpoint I think
that game has no right to be as
enjoyable as it is
correct yeah I don't know the simulator
games I hate yes yeah they really
understood very deeply the appeal of pal
like slash R power wash porn and they're
like we need to make a game of this and
then they do this stuff somebody
tagged me on some Instagram thing where
they were like a lot of piss recommended
power wash simulator and it was
literally just power wash game and it
was dog [ __ ] so I don't take
recommendations anymore and I was like I
didn't recommend it I said I couldn't
stop playing it that is not the same as
a recommendation same with me and
Destiny don't worry I didn't tell you to
play it
oh and I've like been a bit sick lately
so I'm just there like just [ __ ]
power washing my brain like why after
washing my brain just people just
because some folks can't stop you know
taking I don't know if they have a
gambling addiction just because they
can't stop thank you good there you go
you've heard it here don't recommend it
it's the same as gambling okay they're
the same thing just watch yourself
you're gambling with the world's water
supply that's right but you get the the
like pleasure of power washing that you
know universally everybody understands
but you don't have to Lug around any
Machinery you just power wash I also
went for the achievement where you have
to get the soccer ball up the playground
slide and oh I didn't know that once oh
my God it took me so long like to the
extent that I almost hated the game
sounds like an abusive relationship this
game yeah there's just something about
it man it's like it's like yeah it's
like dating someone who's like just very
addictive for no reason they don't give
you anything back just occasionally a
nice ding I was gonna say you're dating
somebody's really dirty interesting
but this is actually the second highest
rated game of the year on Steam after
the God of Wars PC Port
so it's not just like weird nerds who
are into it at us it's like basically
everyone that plays it it's just so
satisfying I feel like I should make a
video about it I think I'm gonna I was
also going to and then I was like I just
want to sit on my couch and play it I
was like no but I think when you do your
q a sec do your q a videos right it's
the perfect one we're like I'm just
gonna do some q a and if you have you in
the corner ask about power washing while
answering questions that's like the old
one that's like the old you know the old
like leafy videos or whatever they used
to have the the people doing the the
Counter-Strike you know
correct but there are certain games
where you just watch it and that's okay
like it's just got that watchable
quality where it doesn't matter what
[ __ ] someone's spouting in the
background you're okay just to keep
watching you know yeah yeah that's a
good idea I want to do that with like
the uh the old uh SpongeBob Krusty Krab
Burger flipping
nickelodeon.com and I'll be like hey
guys so today we're going to talk about
this YouTube drama
Bob clicking flipping burgers
of YouTube where people were playing
Counter-Strike and cod but like talking
about drama
wild yeah I uh Ralph how why do you
think it's good
oh I can't articulate it
a power wash yeah
um I've never really I mean like
it's just
part of me got all like philosophical
and being like life is life is hard okay
life is hard and to get things done is
it's a lot and the world is overwhelming
okay this this is actually a legitimate
line of thought that I had at one point
and I'm like we're power washing it's so
simple and so satisfying and so
achievable and I think part of its
success has to come from the fact that
in this like crazy worlds with all the
[ __ ] going down you can just sit there
and you know that at the end of it the
playground is clean you know that's a
nice feeling and so I don't know how
real that is as an actual like you know
pillar of this game success but that's
definitely something that I felt while I
was playing I mean there is something I
can do those little dings aren't doing
something oh man I was like all I was
like that that Meme you guys got any
more of those dings they know it they
made a shirt that's like they sent me a
shirt that says ding no yes
where's my shirt Square Enix okay where
I want my damn ding shirt how long
oh I mean I mean like I I've seen people
yeah the idea is finish it yeah I think
there's there's
30 stages yeah yeah yeah but they didn't
get like the the motorcycles oh is that
it let me see oh [ __ ]
I'm going to go buy that I love it
um but you see people with like 300
hours on Steam because again it's that
kind of game where you know you put on a
podcast and you do it I listen to an
audiobook yeah like a Warhammer book and
you know you can whatever like it's the
goal is to get through it quickly even
clean [ __ ] yeah yeah correct and also
the co-op aspect like if you've got
buddies and you just like want to hang
out and catch up with a friend or
whatever and be like hey let's just chat
what's what can we play Escape simulator
that sounds pretty stressful how about
power wash yeah yeah buddy so yeah so
it's been out for a while and only
access and just came out on console and
fully released and uh there's some new
content but it seems like they'll
probably Continue to update it I imagine
again I don't necessarily recommend it
I'm not telling you it's a good game I'm
telling you I like it maybe I recommend
it very strongly rules if it's on Game
Pass you know check it out Jada I think
it's okay pause I'm not sure it is it is
I don't think it's for everyone
but I did play it okay this is [ __ ] up
I played it so I just had the surgery to
get rid of migraines and one thing that
would always cause me migraines was
staying up too late and so I haven't had
a migraine since I had the surgery and
so I stayed up till 7am playing power
wash simulator because I was like I'm
free and I played it for so long that my
hand hurt because you hold down RT the
whole time I had my hand on RT for like
seven [ __ ] hours there's a button
there's a top press there's a toggle
it's like the left d-pad button or
whatever please oh my God
we're sorry
oh good to know
that is bad I didn't you could just
toggle it oh
my God I thought they thought of
everything Alana a woman breaking live
on stream in real time in 4k
she's like she's like pointing at
squares
don't pay for this uh Ralph do you have
any uh Destiny updates for us I asked
begrudgingly oh God here we go yeah they
just finished their season and um I
liked it but I don't I I continue to say
that it's not a game that I recommend to
people it's not going to be a game I
recommend for probably another two years
until they fix their new player
experience and they stop deleting
content that you paid for
um but who knows if that'll ever happen
but um look the bottom line is if you
are a destiny fan you already know
everything that I'm saying you are
already playing it and you were already
happy anybody else that's not a destiny
fan good stay that way for at least a
little while and check in a bit later
that's the tldr and Destiny great
fascinating appreciate the update yeah
all right um how have we not brought up
Dragon's Dogma too yet oh my God I guess
there's not that much to say other than
coming in from Left Field that was that
was my most hyped announcement but it's
still not my most anticipated game
because it's like well we don't haven't
seen anything cool t-shirt yeah cool
t-shirt yeah I I was sure like oh they
announced the uh that what is it the
10th anniversary thing and I'm like oh
cool this this could be it because
they're like hey fans and newcomers
might want to tune in but then like they
would they start going through the whole
history and it's 13 minutes and there's
only 30 seconds left I was like it's not
it's not happening that that's house and
then boom baby and I screamed and I
screamed so I lost it I never played
still never played the first by the way
can you give me like the give me the 15
second like this is why everyone
absolutely froths it's like open world
DND with Devil May Cry ish combat and
Shadow of colossal style climbing on
Monsters some dark soulsiness but also
the story fantastic and the world
evolves so much yes it is described
every single game all at once and the
best version
okay right okay
rules man Japanese developers decided to
make a western like medieval fantasy
yeah yeah like it was inspired by
Dungeons and Dragons the whole like
Gathering a party together and going and
and that's what you can like bring in
other people's like characters that they
made and then like you can import them
and tag along with them like it's a
really fascinating do you think it holds
up like if I was to play it tomorrow
yeah I'll be like yeah I think there are
some rough edges uh oh yeah it's kind of
like a clean she came but that said I do
this is like contentious among the
community uh but I do recommend new
players play Docker risen instead of
Dragon's Dogma again was part of that
Euro at Capcom would release a game and
then would release the same game with
like a second name a year later right
Dark Arisen gives you technically the
ability to fast trouble
um and so for a lot of people I think
people fall off of uh the original
Dragon's Dogma because there's no fast
travel and it can be better so I would
recommend Dockers because it gives you
these crystals that let you fast travel
um but yeah it's just like some of the
content in that game too it has it has
some of the
from soft appeal of walking into a room
and not knowing what the [ __ ] is going
to be in that room and then the thing is
Giant and it's a grim reaper and your
whole [ __ ] party's dead and you're
like oh my God it does that stuff too
but it is more accessible than dogs
potentially not more accessible which is
easier
um yeah yeah that's cool that's cool
definitely yeah there's your personality
and style yeah there are enough rough
edges while I know like some people
couldn't quite get through it but if you
power through it I think you're gonna
find like you're gonna get why so many
people are fascinated by this and why so
many people want a sequel because if
they can take that to the next level
um with a sequel It's it's gonna be
amazing the porn system was like clearly
D inspired in a really cool way you
basically get what system porn you
shouldn't question it Ralph everyone
else always questions it you pronounce
porn the same way I do okay oh okay I
really did I really did think my head oh
porn I'm like what and then and then you
sit down no
um the porn system powen has
your you can you can use
a you get to shape their AI a little bit
and you can like import pawns from your
friends and become the party members I
really was thinking the second thing I
was thinking about like a pawn shop like
you sell items in the game like that's
cool so we're actually talking about
chess pieces okay now I'm with you this
is the on the third trial we're talking
about party members okay but you can get
one from your friends that like they've
dressed they've given a certain
personality and certain equipment and
you can like go to this little like Hub
thing where you like swap
it's like it's definitely cult classic
in a way that it's like goofy stuff
going on like whatever reason is like
it's not like it's um
I'm not surprised that it's not the most
popular game in the universe but I have
a lot of love for it I imagine it would
still hold up
check it out
hey uh did you guys even guys haven't
played Hot Wheels Sports uh thoughts of
Hot Wheels yet have you no
I I was given the thing to like go into
the Beta I just didn't have time this
whole week to do much of anything so
good you haven't touched it yet Jake no
I like the other Hot Wheels game show
but Oh you mean Unleashed yeah last year
yeah yeah that was cool yeah yeah so
does this have loop-de-loops oh it does
yeah
no no no no no it's actually so
fascinating because what they've really
done is they've created this massive
gigantic Hot Wheels track that spreads
across all of these different biomes so
there's like there's like you go into a
volcano you go into this like Frosty
Peaks you go along the shoreline you go
into this dense jungle and there's
literally just big orange Frost Wheels
um Hot Wheels track everywhere and loop
the loops and the Magnetic tracks and
some of the tracks are actually water
slides or whatever like it's crazy
still have like a Forza style Hub world
um well yes absolutely so imagine like
that that is the map there's one giant
Overworld so instead there's the map of
Mexico right and then separately there's
now the the forts a Hot Wheels map that
has lots of different race events across
it but it's a huge map like it's I don't
even know how long it would take where
Racers go when they die yeah it is
and it's but oh man it is so nice and
just so visually over oring because like
I'm playing it on my TV at you know 4K
whatever it looks so stunning but it's
almost like it's amazing that this thing
exists because you ultimately have what
is perhaps the finest racing game on the
market today in terms of its like
handling and it's committed to detail
and it's like you know presentation but
they've also made just a goofy ass Hot
Wheels game and it's like that's
incredible like no other triple there's
no way you could have got that amount of
money yeah into the Hot Wheels game even
Hot Wheels Unleashed last year which was
fantastic doesn't hold a candle to this
in terms of presentation you know so so
um I really recommend it Forza Horizon
but I think I asked this before we went
live I know that Forza Horizon has
previously had Hot Wheels content is
this different from that I actually
wouldn't know because I didn't play the
number three one so yeah
either way you're using your cars or are
you using like specific Hot Wheels you
can use any cars you like you can use
your your yeah your um your Halo warthog
on the Hot Wheels track and it's fine
but there's also a whole bunch of new
Hot Wheels cars as well and there are
these really cool missions that they
tell you the history of Hot Wheels while
you're doing them so you're like racing
this race and they're like Hot Wheels
started back at this period where this
guy met this friend and he's like we
want to make little cars and like they
tell you the whole history of the of the
franchise that's pretty and I love it
I'm like I love these missions let's go
in more Hot Wheels history please uh
it's so good in general I just finished
yeah
four though oh
okay is that the UK one five is the best
so I just finished the UK one like a few
weeks ago for no reason so then I feel
like I need a break before I play five
even though I know five's supposed to be
incredible I'm just like give me I need
to wait I've played every fourth of
writing game it's just just need a
couple more years in there you know sure
and then I'll get right into Hot Wheels
and I'll let you know what I think when
we still do this show
um when the next Fallout comes out
here we are definitely I'll be alive
definitely yeah sure for sure Ralph's
still playing Destiny but the auto Wilds
2 is out so that's right everyone's
really coming up skill up it's gonna be
great out of Wilds or out of Worlds oh I
was gonna say right okay yeah that is
coming up I was on brand all right well
played last night I love it
um and I think that's everything
yeah
we've almost definitely forgotten
something that people are going to be
upset about but hey yep but that's yeah
have fun you know whatever it's fine
shout out to the Calista protocol I'd
really like to play it yeah so yeah yeah
definitely multibuses that is a good
question I have not played it no I
haven't actually no downloaded it
haven't touched it yet it counts how was
the download experience
all right excellent so good all right
New York the download speeds let me tell
you
we'll take it
um all right how big is that game
actually
is like a couple iron Giants in it
that answers that
I enjoyed all right
on that note uh thank you all for
joining me so much we'll probably do
another one of these in another several
months I guess uh young where can people
find you what are you up to uh you know
same old same old though you can find me
on youtube.com
yeah for videos for just randomtakes
twitter.com yeah and then voiceover
stuff youngavio.com and yeah I just look
forward to just the usual hell yeah uh
Ralph how about you
I am show up you will find me over at
skillup on the YouTubes and or Twitter
unfortunately what you working on
um playing for holders actually and I
wasn't planning on reviewing it but I
love it so much I think I will and
um then I oh I've got a preview coming
out this weekend for something I'm not
allowed to talk about yet exciting
exciting it's it's something that is
coming soon and it's on people's Radars
and I'm looking forward to talking about
it very cool basically meatball
uh Jake how about you uh you can find me
on gameranks uh on the before you buy
videos and on Fridays the new show uh
also my personal YouTube channel
youtube.com Jake baldino
it's available on podcast platforms and
also on the show up Channel we did that
every two weeks with uh the
completionist and Lucy James and uh it's
been super fun we had a good time yeah
so far so good check that out uh thank
you all for joining me thanks to
everyone in the chat
every time
it's so good